FEDERAL PRISON IF CONVICTED.
>> Tucker: INTERESTING.
EMILY, THANKS SO MUCH FOR THAT
REPORT.
IT’S A WEIRD STORY.
WHY DID SHE COME BACK TO THIS
COUNTRY, SHE HAD TO KNOW IT HAVE
KNOWN SHE WOULD BE ARRESTED, SHE
WAS LIVING ABROAD, SHE HAD
FOREIGN PASSPORTS, PROBABLY MORE
GOING ON HERE THAN WE KNOW SO
HERE’S A THOUGHT EXPERIMENT.
OKLAHOMA CITY IS ONE OF THE MOST
CONSERVATIVE METRO AREAS IN THE
UNITED STATES, DONALD TRUMP WON
ALMOST 50% OF THE VOTE THERE.
IMAGINE IF THE CONSERVATIVES WHO
PRESUMABLY RUN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IN THE CITY SENT AN
EMAIL TO EVERY AFRICAN-AMERICAN
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEE TELLING THEM
TO REPORT TO A SPECIAL MEETING.
IMAGINE THAT WHEN THOSE
EMPLOYEES ARRIVED, BLACK
EMPLOYEES ONLY, NOBODY ELSE
ALLOWED, THEY WERE INFORMED THAT
THE FACT THEY WERE BLACK WAS
DEEPLY OFFENSIVE.
IN FACT IT WAS A KIND OF CRIME,
THE ONLY WAY TO ATONE FOR THE
SIN OF THEIR BLACKNESS WAS TO
APOLOGIZE FOR IT, APOLOGIZE FOR
BEING BORN BLACK AND WORK TO
SHUT ALL TRACES OF YOUR BLACK
IDENTITY.
STOP SPENDING SO MUCH TIME
AROUND YOUR BLACK FRIENDS, STOP
REPEATING THINGS YOUR BLACK
PARENTS TOLD YOU GROWING UP,
STARTED BIDDING OUT LOUD THAT
YOU HATE YOURSELF FOR HAVING
BLACK SKIN.
IMAGINE IF THAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED IN THIS COUNTRY, WHAT
WOULD YOU THINK OF IT?
YOU BE HORRIFIED, OBVIOUSLY,
IT’S CLEARLY DISGUSTING.
IT IS IMMORAL TO ATTACK PEOPLE
FOR HOW THEY WERE BORN, IT’S
ALWAYS IMMORAL.
IT’S ALSO ILLEGAL.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WOULD
NEVER TOLERATE SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
THE CIVIL RIGHTS DIVISION WOULD
SHUTDOWN THE PROGRAM TONIGHT AND
WOULD BRING CRIMINAL CHARGES
AGAINST THE PEOPLE WHO RAN IT
AND YOU WOULD APPLAUD THEM AS
THEY DID THAT AND WE WOULD, TOO.
SO WITH THAT IN MIND, CONSIDER
WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW AND
ONE OF AMERICA’S MOST LIBERAL
CITIES, SEATTLE.
FOUR YEARS AGO, HILLARY CLINTON
GOT 80% OF THE VOTE IN SEATTLE,
THERE ARE MANY PLACES MORE LOYAL
TO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
RECENTLY THE CITY OF SEATTLE
SUMMONED ITS WHITE EMPLOYEES AND
ONLY ITS WHITE EMPLOYEES TO A
MEETING AND INFORMED THEM THEIR
SKIN COLOR IS A CRIME, THE CITY
CALLED THIS ANTIRACISM TRAINING.
EVENTS LIKE IT ARE TAKING PLACE
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY RIGHT NOW
IN SCHOOLS, LOCAL GOVERNMENTS,
CORPORATIONS, THE MILITARY.
THE CITY OF SEATTLE NAMED ITS
TRAINING SESSION "INTERRUPTING
INTERNALIZED RACIAL SUPERIORITY
AND WHITENESS."
CITY JOURNAL WANTS TO KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT WENT ON IN A
MEETING LIKE THAT SO HE FILED A
PUBLIC RECORDS REQUEST.
HERE’S WHAT HE FOUND.
WHITE EMPLOYEES IN SEATTLE WERE
INFORMED THAT THEIR SO-CALLED
"WHITE QUALITIES" WERE OFFENSIVE
AND UNACCEPTABLE.
THOSE QUALITIES INCLUDED
PERFECTIONISM, OBJECTIVITY AND
INDIVIDUALISM.
THE EMPLOYEES WERE TOLD TO STOP
EXHIBITING THESE CHARACTERISTICS
AND INSTEAD THEY WERE ORDERED TO
UNDERTAKE "THE WORK OF UNDOING
YOUR OWN WHITENESS."
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE THAT, IN
ORDER TO ERASE THE TRAITS THEY
WERE BORN WITH, WHITE EMPLOYEES
IN SEATTLE WERE ORDERED TO GIVE
UP THE FOLLOWING.
THEY WERE ORDERED TO GIVE UP
COMFORT, THEY WERE ORDERED TO
GIVE UP SPENDING TIME WITH THEIR
FAMILY.
THEY WERE ORDERED TO GIVE UP ITS
GUARANTEED PHYSICAL SAFETY,
CONTROL OVER OTHER PEOPLE IN THE
LAND, RELATIONSHIPS WITH SOME
OTHER WHITE PEOPLE.
NICETIES FROM NEIGHBORS AND
COLLEAGUES AND "THE CERTAINTY OF
EARDROPS."
PREPARE TO BE UNEMPLOYED, PALE
EMPLOYEES OF SEATTLE, YOUR COLOR
DISCUSS US.
ALL THAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED IN
SEATTLE.
CHECK OUT THE PIECE IN CITY
JOURNAL IF YOU WANT MORE DETAILS
ON IT BUT ATROCITIES AREN’T JUST
HAPPENING IN SEATTLE, THERE
HAPPENING EVERYWHERE.
SOME WILL ALMOST CERTAINLY
HAPPENED IN YOUR KIDS TO SCHOOL
THIS FALL, NO ONE WILL ASK YOUR
PERMISSION BEFORE THEY DO IT,
THEY WILL JUST ATTACK YOUR
CHILDREN FOR HOW THEY WERE BORN.
THE PEOPLE DOING THE ATTACKING
WOULD TELL YOU HOW OPPOSED THEY
ARE TO GAY CONVERSION THERAPY
BECAUSE OF COURSE, IT’S IMMORAL
TO TRY TO CHANGE PEOPLE’S
INTRINSIC QUALITY.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT IRONY,
THIS ISN’T ABOUT PRINCIPLES,
IT’S ABOUT HATE, HUMILIATION,
AND POWER.
IT’S ABOUT HURTING PEOPLE, IT
ALWAYS IS.
TELLING PEOPLE THEY ARE INFERIOR
BECAUSE OF THEIR SKIN COLOR WAS
WRONG WHEN IT HAPPENED 60 YEARS
AGO IN ALABAMA, IT IS EVERY BIT
AS WRONG WHEN IT HAPPENS AT YALE
OR GOOGLE HEADQUARTERS OR YOUR
KIDS ELEMENTARIES WILL BE EIGHT
ATTACKING PEOPLE ON THE BASIS OF
THE RACE IS A SIN, THERE IS
NOTHING WORSE FOR A COUNTRY.
THEY CAN TRY TO DISGUISE IT WITH
ORWELLIAN TERMS LIKE
"ANTIRACISM" BUT THIS IS THE
PUREST KIND OF RACE HATE, IT
WILL DESTROY AMERICA FASTER THAN
ANYTHING ELSE, DON’T PUT UP WITH